prince harry and meghan markle are
celebrating their third wedding
anniversary
it's magic it's pretty amazing and on
their special day
the couple's foundation is teaming up
with world central kitchen to build
their next community relief center in
india
the country is currently experiencing a
devastating covet 19 crisis
india's total virus cases have exceeded
25 million
as of tuesday harry and megan center
will be based in mumbai providing quote
relief
and resilience as well as healing and
strength for those who need it
the center can also be quickly activated
as emergency response kitchens or
vaccination sites for future crises
world central kitchen teams have been
serving 20 000 fresh meals daily to
frontline hospital workers
and to kova quarantine centers in india
the sussexes i think feel very far away
from us
over here in the uk they're they're in
la they're putting
they're putting their time and energy
into really important causes
i think there is a sense that um you
know the sussexes will now be focusing
on more global efforts
now that they're based in the us another
announcement
on their wedding anniversary lifetime
revealed who will be playing the duke
and duchess of sussex
in the upcoming movie harry and megan
escaping the palace
that's jordan dean as the prince and
cindy morton who will be playing the
actress
the film comes after 2018's harry and
megan a royal romance
and megan harry you look
lovely and 2019's harry and megan
becoming royal
if i don't speak up before the wedding
the world is just gonna see me as a girl
in a dress
the third movie will center on recent
events in the couple's life since
stepping down as senior members from the
royal family in order to make a future
for themselves and their son archie
it will also address megan's growing
isolation and sadness
disappointment that the firm was not
defending them against press attacks
and harry's fear that history would
repeat itself
a reference to his late mother princess
diana's death
the fictional movie has been greenlit
for a fall 2021 premiere